عمت الفرحه والسعاده ارجاء هذا البيت بحفل
عرس تقليدي اقامته عائله عروس قبل زفافها
بيوم وفقا للعادات والتقاليد المغربيه لكن
الحفل البهيج في قريه اجنت الغوم اخذ منحا
غير متوقع عندما ضرب الزلزال على حين غره
وبشده
[موسيقى]
بدل المشهد الى فوضى وظلام
وسراخ بدا الناس ينادون على افراد اسرهم
وقد استبدلوا اضاءه الكهرباء بانوار
الهواتف المحموله ومع انقشاع غبار الهزه
بدات تتكشف معالم الكارثه اصيب طفل في
الثامنه من العمر عندما سقطت صخره على
راسه فاصابت
بجروح ظل المنزل قائما بينما تحولت القريه
الى انقاض واصبح الكثير من سكانها بلا ماو
الان ولكن لم تحدث
وفيات دفن الزلزال متعلقات العروسين تحت
الانقاض واصاب العريس بخوف شديد على عروسه
وهو ينتظرها في قريته زل العائله
اردنا ان نحتفل ثم وقع الزلزال لم اكن
اعرف ما اذا كان علي ان اقلق على قريتها
ام على
قريتي حفل زفاف حبيبه اجدير بمزارع التفاح
محمد بضاد تحول الى ما يشبه لوحه الحياه
على حافه الموت مناسبه اجتماعيه انقذت
العديد من الارواح جاء كثير من الناس من
القرى المحيطه باج الغوم للاستمتاع
باحتفال عائله العروس لينجوا بذلك من مصير
مجهول ربما كان ينتظرهم تحت الانقاض لولا
خروجهم للمشاركه في الحفل والمصير المروع
الذي نج منه سكان القريه كان واضحا للعيان
على بعد بضعه كيلومترات اسفل الطريق
الجبلي المتعرج المؤدي الى مراكش حيث ضمرت
قريه تكحت بالكامل تقريبا وقتل العش من
سكانها لكن رغم نجاه سكان قريه اجنت الغوت
لا يزالون بحاجه مسه الى المساعده وبات
جميع الناجين في القريه عائله كبيره
يتقاسمون امدادات الضئيله